rock my face,
tu es une star de premier plan, maintenant
concentre-toi sur le bien,
tout cela en vaudra la peine une fois que nous aurons rencontré
notre bébé parfait, je veux ça aussi
[Musique]
cette femme, je pense qu'elle me suit,
une tonne de médicaments que tu prends beaucoup  ton esprit
tu as un penchant particulier pour transformer
les rêves en cauchemars tu te reposes juste
ma chère
[Musique]
chérie oh mon Dieu je l'ai fait puis-
je voir l'écran un instant tu
veux un Oscar tu le veux autant qu'un
bébé oui
[Musique]
Je ne comprends pas l'envie de créer un
enfant inutile qui se nourrit de ton corps
[Musique]
quelque chose m'arrive, la
douleur est une pierre de touche de la croissance
[Musique]
étrangère [
Musique]
[Musique]
délicate Première le 20 septembre sur FX
stream  sur Hulu